you
hello and welcome from the royal swedish
academy of sciences well we've just
discovered who has received the 2010
nobel prize in chemistry with me to
discuss this prize is Professor large
telander the chairman of chemistry prize
committee professor Jolanda thank you
very much for talking to us could we
begin by you telling us who's been
awarded the 2010 devel prize in
chemistry the price square was awarded
to three scientists Richard heck 18
negishi and Akira Suzuki and what do
they receive the prize for they
developed the palladium-catalyzed cross
coupling for making carbon-carbon bonds
in organic synthesis and we'll go into
more detail about this this process but
just to ask a general question first why
is this reaction and other reactions
that chemists use so important for
chemistry nowadays because if you want
to synthesize more complicated natural
compounds such as the ones you can
isolate from bacteria and different
fungi and so on then you need this tool
because otherwise you can't make it and
you cannot get enough for testing and
medicines and so on so it's something
that chemists use to construct compounds
from scratch yes and especially
complicated natural compounds consisting
of very many molecules then you need
this tool otherwise you cannot make it
and what makes palladium-catalyzed
cross-coupling so important for chemists
because it can form new carbon-carbon
bonds and this is the the essential
thing for all molecules in life they
consist of carbon and you have to create
and and break carbon-carbon bonds and
here is an very good way of making new
carbon-carbon bonds so allows chemists
to make more complicated chemical
Snicket before yes exactly with good
efficiency and so on and so what
examples do we have of chemicals that
chemists have created using this method
that couldn't have been created before
for example we have in medicines we have
the
great number they say even twenty-five
percent of all medicines that are made
synthesized today are made by one of
these reactions so it's a huge impact on
on the pharmaceutical industry and so
how does this work well the trick is
that carbons are rather unreactive by
themselves but if you bring in close
enough together then they can react and
palladium has this magic property that
it can bind to different carbons and
make them come very close together and
then they react on the very mild
conditions so it brings carbon atoms
together which allows them to react and
Bowl together yes exactly and so could
you take us through the the key
breakthroughs that each of the three
lawyers made in developing this process
as the first one was was Hecht that the
most inspired by some industrial product
chemistry in in Germany which showed
that you can use palladium as a catalyst
for different reactions and he further
developed that and made it into a
process that worked for making
carbon-carbon bonds in many different
examples and then the other two made
because his reaction cannot be applied
to all kind of compounds so then they
complement this by finding other way so
you can make it broader so you can work
with all kind of different organic
compounds and under what conditions this
reaction work it works on the mild
conditions you say you don't need any
high pressure high temperature something
so it can it's a mild temperatures and
and not strange solvents and things like
this and that makes it it doesn't create
as much waste product and like normal
chemical senses you get a lot of things
you have to take care of but boron and
sink and so on they are not very toxic
so it's an idea thing for scaling up in
industry and could you give a sense of
when these discoveries were made when
was this method developed and refined
the first one was almost 40 years ago
hex reactions and the other ones what
about 30 years ago and then it took all
the way up to nineteen ninety before
people really start
realize how great these things were and
then it is just developed very quickly
and so you mentioned pharmaceuticals but
could you give us an idea of of other
chemicals that are made yes a lot of
agriculture products you know for
example to keep a fan di away from
grapes and things like this and then in
plastic industry onion electronics to
code chips and to make light emitting
compounds and so on so it's a very
general thing you can use it all over
and so you mentioned that the work was
done decades ago and the price is being
awarded in the year 2010 what
developments have they been that made
the case for this subject it to be the
prize so convincing this year well we
have of course looked at this for quite
a long time now and and but it is a very
complicated feed and very many players
and it took us quite a while to really
sort out who was the real first ones and
the ones versi of the price so that's
why it took some time so there are many
players involved and so I you say it
took some time to make the decision so
could you go into what the the
committee's rationale was for for
focusing on the achievements of these
particular chemists in question I mean
of course we make searches you know we
get nominations and then we order
investigations from different earlier
laureates and so on and let me try to
get this together to a coherent picture
who should be the best one for this year
and and we should give the price to the
best discovery or improvement in
chemistry and we think this year this
was clearly this thing if you look at
the three Lords achievements you say
those three achievements from each of
the Lord's were the key moments in the
development and refinement of this
technique yes and they were quite
independent they haven't been postdoc to
each other or something so they were
completely independent in different
parts of the world we think this is very
great and my final question is have you
spoken to laureates
yes we spoke to them through the
telephone this morning we could reach
all three of them and they seem to be
very satisfied and you even got got in
contact with Professor heckis in the
Philippines yes yes yeah he was a little
shocked but he recovered very quickly
and the reaction of the other two
laureates they were very happy most of
them susuki said he had no idea he would
get it so it was surprised professor
telander thank you very much thank you
visit nobelprize.org to find out more
information about this prize and to
listen to exclusive interviews with the
new laureates you can also keep up to
date with regular news updates from our
facebook and twitter channels and for
the very first time we're giving you the
opportunity to put your questions to all
this year's laureates on youtube visit
www apprised for more details that's
about it from this live webcast tomorrow
it's a turn of the literature prize will
be broadcasting that announcement live
at one p.m. central european time but in
the meantime it's goodbye from all of us
at Nobel Prize org
you